[Musica]
e grazie
se potesse scegliere di viaggiare nel
tempo in qualunque anno
vorreste rivivere il passato o andare a
vedere il futuro che ci attende
questa è una domanda che mi piace fare
spesso a persone molto diverse tra loro
e in particolare quando parlo ad esempio
con i miei studenti più sono giovani e
più rispondono che non vedono l'ora di
vedere cosa come sarà il futuro futuro
che li attende se invece lo chiedo a
persone più vicine all'età dei miei
genitori tendono a rispondere che
vorrebbero rivivere il passato
probabilmente perché conoscono molto
bene quegli anni hanno anche un po di
nostalgia
la verità è che il passato lo conosciamo
molto bene
per darvi un ordine di grandezza tutti i
contenuti e ha creato l'uomo
dall'origine tempi al 2003 sono circa 5
exabyte di contenuti e un exabyte un
miliardo di gigabyte che probabilmente
un ordine di grandezza che conoscete
meglio
tra l'altro questa quantità di
informazioni continua a crescere in
maniera esponenziale nel 2013
cinque i sabati contenuti venivano
creati addirittura ogni 10 minuti quindi
il passato lo conosciamo veramente bene
abbiamo un grandissimo punto
interrogativo sul futuro quindi il tema
è capire come ci immaginiamo questo
futuro
in realtà ci si divide sempre tra due
scenari tra loro tra alternativi ne
approfitto per chiedere a voi chi di voi
è ottimista sul futuro per alzata di
mano chi di voi invece è pessimista si
aspetta che gli anni a venire saranno
più negativi di quelli presenti
ok molto interessante è un'altra domanda
quale sarà il ruolo della tecnologia nel
determinare il nostro futuro è evidente
che la tecnologia sarà sarà ovviamente
la chiave di volta per andare in una
direzione rispetto che nell'altra
ma quanto noi stessi come singoli
individui possiamo influenzare il futuro
del mondo
noi siamo veramente in grado di
influenzarlo come singoli possiamo solo
una persona su sette miliardi e mezzo
quindi siamo talmente piccoli da non
poter creare un impatto
e in questi giorni abbiamo visto
l'apertura dei telegiornali un video
particolarmente forte che è stata la
morte di un orso polare che dopo
settimane che cercava cibo è venuto a
mancare proprio per il surriscaldamento
globale che era sciolto il ghiaccio e
non gli ha permesso di trovare
nutrimento quindi davanti a questi
eventi come ci sentiamo noi cosa
pensiamo di poter fare davanti un
qualcosa che è talmente lontano dalla
nostra quotidianità come il
surriscaldamento globale probabilmente
la risposta più normale sarebbe io non
posso fare niente per un tema così
grande spetta magari ai governi
organizzazioni più grandi c'è dunque chi
ipotizza un futuro apocalittico
anche perché io personalmente
rappresento la generazione che è
cresciuta con vent'anni di telegiornali
con notizie tendenzialmente negative e
cosa pensate che quale effetto pensare
che abbiano 20 anni di telegiornali con
un isee negative è stato dimostrato che
anche facendo alcuni esperimenti sui
social media
mostrando alcune persone dei contenuti
tendenzialmente negativi dopo un po di
tempo anche i contenuti da loro creati
avranno un umore più più negativo e
guardando un pochino i film con i quali
siamo cresciuti cosa succede quando la
situazione diventa troppo grave la
soluzione ci hanno insegnato che essere
quella di chiamare qualcun altro chi
andiamo a chiamare andiamo a chiamare i
supereroi la soluzione la riserverà
qualcun altro e verrà qualcuno con
qualche potere speciale per andare a
sistemare la situazione chi di voi da
piccolo non ha pensato almeno una volta
di essere un supereroe meno giocato a
fare supereroi lui ad esempio è e mio
nipote e qualche giorno fa sono andato a
trovare mia sorella gemella sua mamma e
la mia famiglia e l'ho trovato sul
divano che giocava a fare il supereroe
penso addirittura da solo riusciva a
fare sia al buono che è cattivo e questa
cosa mi ami
colpito perché quando siamo piccoli a
noi piace giocare essi però e vediamo
che è un qualcosa che crediamo essere
realistico ma poi col passare del tempo
perdiamo i nostri poteri e li perdiamo
perché purtroppo tutti noi viviamo
all'interno di una bolla una bolla
quotidiana
purtroppo facciamo spesso fatica a
uscire dal nostro contesto al nostro
giro di amicizie all'ambito del lavoro
anche al giro di fonti alle quali
andiamo a prendere notizie
e tutto questo quindi tende un pochino
ad appiattire anche la nostra
considerazione sul resto del mondo noi
pensiamo che la maggior parte nel mondo
sia simile a quello che vediamo quello
che sentiamo in base ai media che
consultiamo poi così è successo
un giorno un mio amico mi manda un link
con un articolo
e l'articolo diceva il futuro è meglio
di quanto credi questo titolo ha subito
attirato la mia attenzione e ho
incominciato a studiare questi temi
nello studiare questi temi ho letto un
libro di peter da mantis sull'abbondanza
con termine che all'inizio non mi era
molto familiare non non lo capivo nel
suo vero significato e una frase
importante è la tecnologia è quella
forza che prende qualcosa di scarso o
inaccessibile e lo rende abbondante
continuando a studiare sia al libro che
altri che altri temi un'altra frase mi
ha chiarito il concetto quando guardiamo
attraverso la lente della tecnologia
poche risorse sono veramente scarse sono
semplicemente inaccessibili tra vari
esempi ne vorrei raccontare uno che per
me sarà abbastanza illuminante e risale
addirittura ai tempi dell'imperatore
tiberio un importante orafo decise di
portare in dono all'imperatore tiberio
un piatto in alluminio che era un
materiale che nessuno conosceva e lui
diceva di essere riuscito ad estrarre
questo nuovo minerale direttamente
dall'argilla attraverso una formula
segreta
il problema era che tiberio aveva la
maggior parte dei suoi tesori composti
da oro e argento
quindi ha detto se arriva un no
materiale più leggero ma luminoso tanto
quanto l'argento se prende piede
probabilmente andrà a svalutare i
mediatori quindi dopo averci pensato un
pochino decise che il dubbio è taglio la
testa a questo scienziato quindi elimina
un problema elimina una formula segreta
e rimango blocco un pochino per qualche
migliaio di anni
l'innovazione il problema che
l'alluminio oggi sappiamo che è
probabilmente il terzo minerale più
presente nella crosta terrestre italiana
e mondiale
e quindi il problema non è la scarsità
della risorsa
mancava semplicemente la tecnologia per
renderla accessibile
quando ho letto questo passaggio la mia
prima considerazione è si è rivolta al
mondo dell'acqua ci sono un miliardo di
persone nel mondo che non hanno accesso
a acqua da poter bere quotidianamente la
metà dei ricoveri ospedali del mondo
sono dovute a persone che hanno ingerito
un acqua non potabile eppure sappiamo
che la terra composta principalmente
d'acqua quindi manca la tecnologia per
renderla disponibile è potabile in tutto
il mondo nel modo migliore e un altro
passaggio di questo libro mi colpì
particolarmente ed è quando parlarono
della democratizzazione del potere di
cambiare il mondo
quindi non dobbiamo più aspettare
supereroi ciascuno di noi può fare
qualcosa di assolutamente impattante per
cambiare il mondo e ho scoperto che
esisteva una realtà che si chiama
singole arti universiti che forma
persone in tutto il mondo l'insegna cosa
sono le tecnologie esponenziali e gli
chiede di lavorare su progetti che
impattino un miliardo di persone nei
prossimi dieci anni
quindi mi è bastato uscire semplicemente
dalla bolla quotidiana all'interno della
quale vivevo per trovarmi catapultato in
un mondo completamente nuovo sono stato
selezionato nel 2015 ho fatto un breve
programma con loro quindi fisicamente
eravamo nel centro di ricerca della fina
merica in silicon valley e in effetti
appena arrivato ilicic hanno subito
chiesto un cambio di approccio un cambio
di paradigma ti dicono smettila di
lavorare su dei progetti piccoli o medi
schiarite a un tavolo ciascun tavolo
rappresenta uno dei grandi problemi
dell'umanità o suprema dell'acqua
niente del cibo della salute
dell'energia e lavora a una soluzione
che infatti un miliardo di persone in
dieci anni usando le tecnologie
esponenziali credo che la prima reazione
di chiunque sia io non potrò mai
lavorare su un progetto di questa
grandezza melo ti dicono ok riuscirai a
farlo se impari usare queste tecnologie
che altri spighe prima di me hanno
raccontato oggi non vi racconterò la mia
esperienza della singola t
ma ci terrei a riassumere un pochino
alcuna cosa che mi hanno particolarmente
colpito in particolare ho capito che
realmente bastano poche persone per
cambiare il mondo oggi delle persone
hanno la possibilità i mezzi e anche le
tecnologie per fare una differenza
concreta ciascuno nel suo piccolo può
cambiarlo anche con pochi strumenti o
relativamente poco tempo questa è una
foto di una ragazza che poi diventata
una mia cara amica lucrezia bisignani
che ha capito che solo nell'africa ci
sono 166 milioni di bambini che non
hanno accesso all'istruzione discussione
quella di base quindi non sono
analfabeti e servirebbero un milione e
mezzo di docenti per andare a insegnare
a questi bambini problema questi docenti
avremo istruirli e mandarli ne fosse più
pericolosi del mondo è meno accessibili
quindi ha trovato una soluzione
tecnologica e sta lavorando a un
applicazione che si può distribuire in
africa e magari anche in altre parti del
mondo per aiutare questi bambini
torniamo dunque la domanda di prima cosa
possiamo fare noi per risolvere sfide
così grandi
ora forse incominciate a essere un po
più chiaro quale può essere il nostro
ruolo attivo e sono convinto che quando
la competenza incontro alla conoscenza
si realizzano progetti magici partiamo
dalla conoscenza un ragazzo a un certo
punto ha scoperto che per risolvere
problema dell'orso quelli del
surriscaldamento globale è più facile
intervenire nel bloccare il fenomeno
della deforestazione che pesa per il 17
per cento rispetto a provare a cambiare
dalla sera alla mattina il problema del
mondo dei trasporti che pesa per il 13
per cento e lui ha detto esiste ci sono
tantissime foreste tropicali a rischio e
vorremmo evitare che questi
magari diventino di scenari apocalittici
come possiamo farlo è andato in una
foresta e s'è reso conto che le persone
che vanno abusivamente a tagliare gli
alberi possono farlo anche in maniera
molto molto vicina ai ranger che
dovrebbero controllare anche 220 a 300
metri non verranno mai colti in
fragrante perché la foresta e piena di
rumore di sottofondo e non si sente
rumore della sega
quindi una volta che lui ha scoperto
queste informazioni la sua competenza la
portata a dire va bene perfetto prende
un semplicissimo telefono cellulare
neanche di ultimissima generazione lo
faccio diventare un antenna e questa
antenna farò in modo che possa mandare
dei segnali al ranger di turno se riesce
a sentire il rumore di coloro che stanno
tagliando gli alberi ha creato il primo
sistema di protezione delle foreste
realtime ed è incredibile perché ha
generato risultati immediati
continuativi e soprattutto scalabili e
questa cosa l'ha fatta anche grazie al
potere della rete perché una volta che
lui ha raccontato questa idea e la
dimostrata spontaneamente dalla rete
hanno cominciato a mandarli i telefoni
che tutti noi teniamo nei cassetti
quando compriamo il modello successivo
la parte che mi piace di più di questa
storia è che non si è inventato una
nuova tecnologia ha semplicemente capito
come utilizzare una tecnologia che tutti
noi abbiamo in tasca per una finalità
diversa
mi ha colpito molto prima un intervento
di papà francesco quando ha parlato che
per cambiare il mondo bisogna essere
creativi però subito pensato alla
creatività di questo giovane ragazzo che
ha visto in un problema una soluzione
particolarmente semplice ed efficace il
potere della rete è incredibile da
questo punto di vista perché ciascuno di
nuovi può fare la differenza con le
tecnologie quotidiane già il nostro
possesso ma soprattutto andando ad
attivare una community di persone che li
possano dare supporto anche senza
conoscerlo semplicemente perché si
appassionano a un'idea e vi racconterò
adesso rapidamente un altro esempio
recente non più di 40 giorni fa c'era
una ragazza che in affido a del piano di
notte è rimasta ferma con la macchina
perché ha finito la benzina
una zona abbastanza pericolosa gli si è
avvicinato all'unica persona in zona che
era un senzatetto johnny e johnny lee ha
detto non ti preoccupare chiuditi dentro
la macchina attorno subito è tornato e
ha speso gli uni gli ultimi 20 dollari
che aveva per comprare una tanica piena
di benzina ha fatto la benzina della
ragazza lei poi ha detto troverò in modo
più star mi i giorni a seguire tornate
agli hare tali soldi li ha dato dei
vestiti è dato di volta in volta pochi
dollari e poi ha detto no devo fare
qualcosa di molto più grande quello che
a riuscire a fare e attivare una
campagna di 30 giorni ha coinvolto
10.500 persone che alla fine hanno
raccolto in questo articolo si parlava
di 320.000 dollari
la cosa ancora più bella è che quando si
attivano delle strategie basate sul bene
in realtà continuano ad andare da sole
quindi da quando il giornalista ha
scritto l'articolo a quando io ho
consultato l'ultimo dato da 320.000
siamo già stati da 400mila credo ci
siano anche grandi margini di
miglioramento
perché quella ragazza non era esperta di
queste strategie e dopo 30 giorni acceso
di chiudere la campagna è finita di
secondo me quando si innesca un brano
positivo si possono fare cose veramente
meravigliose purtroppo la tecnologia è
una moneta a due facce questa è un'altra
cosa che ho capito molto bene perché
esistono ad oggi un miliardo di persone
che non hanno accesso a quelle che
vengono chiamate all seasons ruote
strade che possono essere percorse
durante tutto l'anno un qualunque
stagione c'è una parte del mondo in
realtà una persona su sette che quando
c'è un'allusione pesante o una frana
vengono scollegate da adesso nel mondo e
le nuove tecnologie come i droni ci
permettono di portare loro acqua cibo
medicinali anche quando fisicamente le
strade sono interrotte
la stessa tecnologia del drone però può
essere usata anche per finalità diverse
in questo caso questo è un drone al
quale hanno aggiunto una semplicissima
telecamera termica che può andare in
giro a scansionare il territorio e
rendersi conto se in un appartamento in
un determinato edificio la temperatura
della stanza è più alta rispetto alla
media
vuol dire che in quell'appartamento
stanno producendo droga poi potreste
dire bellissimo è una tecnologia
utilizzata dalla polizia per contro dal
territorio
no è una è un qualcosa che ha ideato
mina vita organizzata in messico per
controllare il territorio
questo vuol dire che la tecnologia è
ovviamente una moneta a due facce e la
criminalità organizzata non vuole più
guadagnare in maniera lineare e vuole
guadagnare in maniera esponenziale e
quindi sta investendo in maniera molto
molto importante su queste tecnologie e
quindi sta a noi prendere parte al
cambiamento e decidere da che parte
stare
un'altra riflessione molto importante
che abbiamo fatto in america è che fatta
100 la popolazione mondiale è abbastanza
evidente che possiamo dire 95 per cento
sono persone che potremmo definire
persone buone persone che se potessero
dare una mano
la darebbero magari il 5 per cento sono
un po più malvagi anche per magari
storie pregresse che hanno avuto nella
vita
il vero problema quando mi hanno un
consulente dei servizi segreti ci ha
raccontato questa storia che nel mondo
siamo principalmente persone per bene
gli ho però fatto notare che noi
possiamo essere persone perbene ma se
ciascuno di noi è chiuso nella nostra
bolla è come se non fossimo forza lavoro
dedicata al bene che esistono invece ci
hanno fatto vedere da satelliti e interi
edifici e migliaia di persone che
timbrano il cartellino per fare lacker
per fare del delle rapine informatiche
quindi non basta dire che la maggior
parte delle persone per bene dovremmo
andare a conteggiare la forza lavoro
quindi quanti lavorano per il bene e
quanti realmente lavorano per creare un
danno quindi sono convinto che chi non
prende parte purtroppo è come se stesse
danno un piccolo vantaggio ai cattivi
quanti di voi vorrebbero dunque
realmente fare qualcosa per cambiare la
vita che vi circonda in questo caso ho
preso una foto de vito margiotta che un
ragazzo che ha conosciuto recentemente
che ha mollato il suo posto in google
per creare una nuova tecnologia per
portare paesi meno avanzati online
il problema dei nostri tempi secondo me
il vero male che tutti col quale tutti
noi abbiamo diciamo affrontare ogni
giorno sono la fretta e la distrazione
continuerò a fare troppe cose e siamo
costantemente distratti e quindi come
possiamo cambiare il mondo
se stiamo continuamente distratti
pensiamo al passato non vediamo l'ora
che sia il futuro stiamo un pochino
perdendo la capacità di creare azioni
concrete nel presente
quindi la risposta principale non ho
tempo di fare una cosa a fin di bene
e da questo punto di vista sono convinto
che l'unica soluzione sia metodologica
personalmente ho trovato una metodologia
che è quella di dedicare il 2 ore al
giorno sistematiche allo studio del mio
lavoro di cui oggi non vi ho parlato
perché non era il caso
ma cerco di fare due esperienze l'anno
di crescita personale che non siano
legate al mio lavoro cerco di uscire
dalla bolla almeno due volte l'anno
ad esempio se non guardassimo la
televisione per un intero anno a livello
mondiale si libererebbe più di un
trilione di ore di surplus cognitivo da
dedicare a qualcos'altro e stiamo
parlando della televisione e io che ho
creato una piccola realtà nel mondo dei
social sarei la persona meno adatta a
dire quello che sto per dire ma son
convinto che la stessa riflessione la
potremmo fare sul mondo dei social media
ai miei studenti dico sempre che la
tecnologia deve sempre essere qualcosa a
vantaggio dell'uomo e mai diventare noi
schiavi della tecnologia quindi ad
esempio ha dato una regola se voi su
facebook su qualunque altro social
vedete per tre volte consecutive e lo
stesso contenuto quindi fate refresh
rivedere lo stesso contenuto uscite da
facebook perché è finita
l'utilità marginale del vostro tempo su
facebook probabilmente stare perdendo
tempo
ma il tempo l'avete quindi alla terza
volta il contenuto
andate su stili tipo ted.com a cercare
uno stimolo e in effetti si dice che
siamo la media delle cinque persone con
le quali passiamo più tempo e mi
piacerebbe pensare che una di queste
cinque persone domani fosse una persona
tecnologica fosse una fonte fosse un tè
di turno o comunque un luogo dove
prendere informazioni interessanti
io chiudo con un ultima riflessione che
alla quale diciamo ho pensato spesso
dopo che ho partecipato a un piccolo
programma di aive globali del forum
presso harvard ci hanno detto immaginate
di essere alla fine dei vostri giorni su
una panchina al mare e vi si siede a
fianco vostro nipote mi guarda e mi dice
nonno
qual è la cosa più importante che tu hai
fatto nella tua vita
tu sei costretto a pensare cosa
veramente fatto sei generato un impatto
quelle all'inizio di un esercizio che ci
hanno fatto fare
che poi ti porta a pensare cose
avresti voluto fare nella tua vita
quindi d'acqua in avanti come general
impatto come sarebbe il mondo se non
fossimo è nato e quali sono gli ostacoli
che ho nel quotidiano per arrivare da da
quello che sono a quello che vuole
arrivare e vi volevo lasciare con questa
riflessione ma soprattutto con una frase
che ho scoperto una settimana fa da uno
studente in questo scambio continuativo
di informazioni che se non si rischiasse
ma nella vita
michelangelo avrebbe dipinto il
pavimento della cappella sistina
quindi vi lascio con questa destinazione
vi ringrazio
[Musica]
[Applauso]